die kollision schon gegeben wenn wir ein
rap text haben wo jemand sagt ich [ __ ]
die [ __ ] tot sie liegt bereits im
wachkoma und ich glaube genau das ist
der punkt was ist kunst und wo endet die
toleranz was die kollision der
grundrecht daten betrifft
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu 310 fragen wir
diskutieren mit künstlern und
kulturschaffenden über kunstfreiheit und
starten direkt mit der ersten frage von
13 fragen mit unserer konflikt frage
müssen wir kunst von den
kunstschaffenden trennen wenn ihr sagt
ja kunstwerk und die personen die das
erschaffen hat und unbedingt getrennt
werden dann geht er aufs grüne feld und
wenn ihr sagt nee nicht trennen dann
geht er ausgebe fit
[Musik]
ok eure position sind klar kommen wir
zum thema michael jackson woody allen
roman polanski die liste geht noch viel
länger es geht um kunstschaffende den
sexualisierte gewalt machtmissbrauch
oder andere verbrechen vorgeworfen
werden wie geht jeden als fans damit um
hörte die musik trotzdem weiter schaut
ihr die filme noch lassen die bilder
hängen oder sagte da vergeht mir ehrlich
gesagt dass spaß an deren kunst ist und
bleibt ein moralisches dilemma aber wie
können wir eigentlich die kunst schützen
wenn der oder die künstlerinnen sich
strafbar macht geht das überhaupt bei
310 fragen sind sich meine gäste wie
üblich erst mal uneinig umso spannender
werden sie am ende dieser folge doch
noch ein kompromiss finden oder
vielleicht sogar eine lösung wir werden
sehen aber jetzt erstmalig auf welcher
seite des feldes würdet ihr dann stehend
grün oder gelb schreibt es mir gerne in
die kommentare ich euch liebe gäste
heißt es ab jetzt wenn ihr der anderen
seite des spielfeldes in einem argument
zustimmen wollte oder einfach bock habt
einen schritt auf die zu gehen weil ihr
euch denkt ja da da gehe ich mit dann
könnt ihr einen schritt einfach nach
vorne laufen und wenn er sagt nein und
das vielleicht auch mitten während
jemand räder zum ausdruck bringen wollt
dann könnt ihr das machen wären die
person spricht ihr könnt das gern
organischen eure bewegungen einfließen
lassen für mich ist natürlich das ziel
so viele von euch wirklich hier am ende
ein kompromiss feld zu sehen mal gucken
ob ich das schaffe peter ich möchte gern
bei dir anfangen mit einer leichten
frage zum einstieg kannst du noch
michael jackson hören ich kann auch
michael jackson hören ich finde das
nicht gut was er wahrscheinlich ganz
sicher ist es ja nicht getan haben
könnte oder sollte aber ich glaube es
ist unmöglich
morgens im bad zu stehen fragen wie
schröder oder bietet zuhören und dann zu
sagen ich kann das jetzt nicht gut
finden
der bei der hat schlechte dinge gemacht
und deswegen ist der song auch schlecht
ich glaube das funktioniert nicht da
geistert man sich selber und kommt in
innere zwänge und konflikte künstler in
und kunstwerk seiten also deiner meinung
nach getrennt werden einlader meisten
fällen ja das ist unsinn dass
das werk und die künstler so verkennt
man muss das trennen weil manche werke
kunstwerke werden einfach sehr viel
größer oder gehören auch dem publikum
und das publikum macht etwas daraus und
das findet deswegen findet man sollte es
unbedingt rennen bei wiener was sagst du
dazu wenn du morgens im bad radio an
hast uns läuft michael jackson gibt es
dann genauso wie peter
ich würde sagen es ist schwierig für
mich michael jackson mittlerweile zu
hören und ich persönlich
erinnere mich dann jedes mal wenn ich
seine stimme ein verhöre obwohl ich weiß
dass an michael jackson songs so viel
mehr menschen auch beteiligt waren er
hat ja nicht den kompletten kosmos
alleine erschaffen dennoch ist seine
stimme die stimme von der person mit der
ich diese vorwürfe identifiziere ich
finde es ist schwierig das kunstobjekt
vom
künstler zu trennen einfach deshalb weil
der künstler der es erschaffen hat hat
es erschaffen mit allen erfahrungen mit
all dem was er ist und mit dem allen was
er gesehen hat und daraus extrahiert und
deswegen kann ich es mir persönlich
nicht vorstellen dass zu trennen ich
weiß nicht wie das gehen soll warum
sollten wir denn deiner meinung nach
kunst und kunstschaffende nicht drin ich
denke
die kunst die man als kunstschaffender
erstellt ja sei es ich als musikerin
oder schriftsteller bildende künstler
diese kunst kommt aus uns heraus als
individuum mit allem was uns
charakterlich ausmacht auch mit allen
erfahrungen die wir gesammelt haben mit
unserer wahrnehmung brille und natürlich
auch mit all dem was wir getan haben und
was wir sind und es ist deswegen
zwangsläufig für mich dass das kunstwerk
was wir produzieren in einer gewissen
weise durch eine nabelschnur mit uns
verbunden bleibt würde man jetzt die
relativ schlechte kunst von adolf hitler
betrachten ja das ist jetzt ein ganz
krasses beispiel und plötzlich sagen ich
hab das sind aber ganz schöne bilder die
da gemalt hat wäre es für uns ganz klar
in der gesellschaft zu sagen ja aber die
wurden von adolf hitler gemalt und
deswegen kann man sie nicht eben aus dem
zusammenhang ziehen und sagen das hat
mit adolf hitler gerne zu tun würdest du
denn da zustimmen bei bina mit den
kunstwerken von adolf hitler also
erstmals aber kein künstler sondern
einen tierarten und einen menschen
ein faschist oder was auch immer aber es
kein künstler und hat auch keine
kunstwerke gemacht er hat vielleicht
gemalt was man vielleicht als kunst
erklären kann ja findet im vergleich von
michael jackson der unter umständen
kinder missbraucht haben könnte mit
adolf hitler bilder gemalt hat ist also
auf der strecke bleiben einfach ganz
viel etappen welt ist für mich der
vergleich nicht gültig wenn es darum
geht ob man künstler und wurde künstler
innen und kunstwerk trennen muss würde
ich sagen dass da gehe ich nicht mit
also wenn wir keine kunst mehr
betrachten dürfen die die von künstlerin
stammt die etwas falsch getan haben oder
oder eine straftat begangen haben dann
wieder und das ist sicherlich eines der
größten oder häufigsten argumente oder
dokumente dann werden die museen
wahrscheinlich fast leer und auch die
kinos derweil die kennt viele künstler
in die sicherlich je nach
straftatbestand medien sei es toben ist
braucht es in die in andere dinge man
muss die dinge einfach
in dem was sie sind belassen und
vielleicht auch die tat der künstler
eben mit einbeziehen in die betrachtung
des kunstwerkes ja aber da muss ich
jetzt gleich wieder sprechen das ist ja
eben die definition was ist kunst und
wer ist ein künstler und diese
definition die endet irgendwo und fängt
irgendwo an und genau deswegen bringe
ich dieses krasse beispiele ja adolf
hitler ist ein eindeutiges beispiel und
deswegen habe ich auch gesagt diese
kunst wird nie als kunst gelten dennoch
danach kommen ganz viele andere stufen
und ab wann ist denn die stufe erreicht
wo du sagt das ist ein künstler und das
ist kunst
doch direkt mal bei der definition von
kunst und von der aufgabe von
künstlerinnen bleiben ecke du bist
herausgeberin eines der größten kunst
magazine deutschlands was würdest du
denn sagen welche aufgabe hat ein
künstler hat eine künstlerin gott was
für
kunstschaffende und ihre werke sind
zunächst einmal etwas ganz
unterschiedliches und trotzdem haben sie
natürlich viel miteinander zu tun ich
würde sagen ein werk ist immer mehr als
sein auto oder sein autorin man merkt
dass vor allem wenn man die
kunstgeschichte betrachtet interessiert
ist uns noch das caravaggio jemanden
umgebracht hat oder wollen wir jetzt
einfach nur seine tollen gemälde sehen
ich glaube dass vor allen dingen im
laufe der zeit irgendwann das werk übrig
bleibt und der autor oder die autorin
der künstler oder die künstlerin immer
unwichtiger wird ein großer teil der
kunst beschäftigt sich mit der frage was
eigentlich kunst ist also sozusagen
diese selbst reflexivität ist ja
ausschlaggebend für die kunst etwas was
adolf hitlers kunst bestimmt nicht hatte
insofern kann man das leicht
aussortieren mal wieder hat er natürlich
völlig recht wenn sie sagt es gibt fälle
diesen klar oder es gibt fälle diesen
grenzwertig aber deswegen mit
dementieren wir darüber also das heißt
für mich hat kunst eine gewisse
komplexität also kunst ist eben hat eine
offenheit und deswegen müssen wir
überhaupt darüber diskutieren wem sie
gehört weil für mich ist kunst eben das
werk das seinen autor seiner autorin
überstrahlt überragt also ein werk das
komplexer ist als das was der künstler
oder die künstlerin
reingesteckt hat deswegen finde ich auch
das mit der nabelschnur das ist
vielleicht die sicht der künstler der
künstlerin aber eigentlich gibt es auch
eine nabelschnur zum rezipienten so
rezipienten und dies vielleicht genauso
wichtig und insofern gehört das
kunstwerk eben auch nicht nur dem der es
erschaffen hat sondern das kunstwerk ist
dann ein kunstwerk wenn es eine
komplexität von seinem eigenen recht hat
und wenn wir da andere sachen drin sehen
können als vielleicht die generation vor
uns als vielleicht ein anderer mensch
und als vielleicht auch der mensch das
gemacht hat anna du bist selbst
künstlerin würdest du ecke da zustimmen
in teilen also das ist sehr komplex ist
und dass auch ein kunstwerk eine eigene
komplexität braucht da würde ich dir auf
jeden fall zustimmen das thema liegt mir
am herzen weil ich selbst bildende
künstlerin bin und immer wieder merke je
mehr mediale aufmerksamkeit ich bekomme
desto mehr trage ich eben auch eine
verantwortung für mein publikum und auch
für jüngere generation außerdem habe ich
das gefühl das ist letzter zeit vermehrt
vorgekommen ist dass fälle von
machtmissbrauch in der medienlandschaft
vorgekommen sind und zwar so oft dass
man das einfach nicht mehr ignorieren
kann ich glaube wir merken also schon zu
beginn dieser diskussion ist es sehr
komplexe schaffte philosoph roland
barthes der hat 1967 geschrieben der tod
des autors und in diesem text schrieb er
darüber dass der text immer losgelöst
von auto oder autorin betrachtet werden
sollte und seiner meinung nach erschafft
die lesende person den text und nicht
der verfasser oder die verfasserin
würdest du ihnen da zustimmen nicht ganz
das ist eine sichtweise aber weil wohl
schon ein bisschen wahrheit trendig ist
dass der künstler ist irgendwann los
lässt also ich meine es auch schon von
allen künstlern gehört zu haben die
gesagt haben wenn das kunstwerk fertig
ist und dass vielleicht ist dann
entlastet das in die welt und dann
gehört es nicht mit mir ist es so ein
bisschen wie der entbindung also diese
nachricht nur von der mission geräte
wurde mit dann gekappt und das werden
jeweils treibst wahrscheinlich
bestätigen können die noch nie ein
fußballstadion im schreiben wollten aber
das publikum gesagt hat wir machen das
jetzt dazu
dieses nabelschnur beispiel das geht
auch finde ich ganz schön vergleich den
der mir immer ein bisschen hilft beim
einer noch sehr harten position zu
bleiben das ist ich betrachte die
künstler als eltern und die kunstwerke
als kinder und klar steckt ganz ganz
viel von den eltern in den kinderjahren
da
sich zusammen mit haben was was
erschaffen was ihnen schon recht ähnlich
ist und man würde nie auf die idee
kommen zu sagen du bist dessen sohn naja
manchen fällen schon aber man sollte
nicht auf die theke und zu sagen deine
eltern waren mies und deswegen geben wir
die erst recht keine chance deswegen
wirst du sofort gecancelt sondern aus st
das hat sich irgendwann einmal gelöst
und wir geben dem es chancen so ein
bisschen zäh es auch bei werk und
künstler werke mit nazi hintergrund
sowie menschen mit nazi hintergrund gibt
es doch heute auch
wenn ich habe ich bin jetzt nicht im
bild rechenwerk mit alles habe ich jetzt
gar nicht so weh aber ich würde auch
sagen meinen die mitte wenn es ein
schönes projekt ist höher das bild also
das ist ein guter christ platz was meint
ihr künstlerinnen vermitteln uns durch
ihre kunstwerke er auch botschaften
haben sie dadurch eine besondere
moralische verantwortung schreibt man
die kommentare an die gelbeseiten ihr
könnt euch jetzt gern positionieren bei
bina du hast dich schon positioniert zu
dem was peter gesagt hast du bist ein
klein glien zugegangen war in kleinstadt
auf ihn zugegangen weil dieses argument
dass er gebracht hat natürlich ist ein
kunstwerk in dem augenblick wo es in die
welt hinaus tritt wird es betrachtet und
natürlich ist es in der dimension des
betrachten des betrachters
etwas anderes als in der dimension des
erschaffen und dem würde ich nie
widersprechen und deswegen gehe ich auch
ein bisschen vor weil ich eben genau
finde das problem liegt in dieser
grauzone erstens was ist wirklich auf
welchen kunstbegriff können wir uns
einigen ja darüber haben wir ja gerade
einen diskurs gehabt ich glaube das ist
auch nicht allen klar was ist kunst und
was ist keine kunst ja und das ist genau
der punkt warum ich hier auf dieser
seite stehe weil ich finde kunstfreiheit
allgemein freiheit begrenzt sich immer
dort wo diese freiheit anderen menschen
schadet und ich finde alles passt gegen
grundrechte
verstößt ja gegen eingriffe richtung
menschenwürde also überall alles was mit
dem mit den grundrechten kollidiert muss
dann noch mal hinterfragt werden ja und
genau das ist der punkt der es so
schwierig macht zu sagen wo es diese
kollisionen gegeben ja ist die kollision
gegeben in dem augenblick wo ich eine
installation mache und jemanden mit der
pumpgun irgendwie erschieße ist da die
kollision gegeben oder ist die kollision
schon gegeben wenn wir ein rap text
haben wo jemand sagt ich [ __ ] die
[ __ ] tot sie liegt bereits im
wachkoma und ich glaube genau das ist
der punkt was ist kunst und wo endet die
toleranz was die kollisionen der
grundrechte betrifft aber etwas und
neues thema eigentlich gemacht als ich
also wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen
also bei michael jackson zum beispiel da
geht es um die frage was hat der mann
gemacht und das findet sie ja nicht in
seinem werk und jetzt hast du aber über
werke gesprochen darum rechte verletzen
und ich für moralische also das sind das
für nicht sind sind zwei
unterschiedliche man muss die fälle
auseinander halten wo es nur darum geht
irgendwie gefällt uns jetzt der die
ethische einstellung des künstlers sich
oder finden wir das im werk gefällt uns
die ethische aussage oder gefallen uns
diese krassen sachen die in dem rap text
vorkommen gefällt uns das nicht also ich
finde das sind zwei und zwei
unterschiedliche fälle und da muss man
sehr unterschiedlich auch über kunst
freiheit reden peter du bist beim
stichwort menschenrechte beim stichwort
grundrechte ein schritt auf bei bena
zugegangen macht es nochmal klären warum
ja ich glaube dass es die grund die die
bassline auf die man sich einigen kann
also man kann sagen wenn ein kunstwerk
ganz offensichtlich gegen die verfassung
verstößt dann muss man nicht mehr groß
mit dem kunstbegriff reden im beispiel
wenn jemand segensbitte geht
vergewaltigt
kannst du sofort auf den index stecken
aber was ist wenn georg base zum
beispiel seien frauen kann nicht malen
das ist eindeutig nicht
verfassungswidrig aber es gibt mir kraft
die nerven ja klar dann kannst du sagen
georg baselitz ist echt ein totaler
trottel und dann kannst du aber immer
noch überlegen findest du seine werke
jetzt interessant oder nicht interessant
also ich find beide also ich finde so
wohl dass er quatsch erzählt als auch
seine werke nicht besonders interessant
aber ich weiß nicht ob sich das eine aus
dem anderen ergibt ist es auch zu weil
ja das weiß ich auch nicht aber jetzt
frage ich mich das jedes mal wenn ich
seine arbeit sehe ich fand die ehemals
studenten eigentlich total gut aber
jetzt kann ich das versaut das ist aber
auch okay ich glaube es ist vollkommen
okay dass man für sich selber sagt
also wie du eben gesagt hat ich bin
total bei dem thema pädophilie
kindesmissbrauch bin ich total sensibel
und deswegen hab ich kein bock michael
jackson zu hören wenn ich total okay ich
finds auch total okay wenn jemand sagt
ich habe einen klub ich engagiere mich
vor dem thema richtig ich mag den nicht
wegen dieser sache bei mir läuft herr
michael jacksons nicht okay man sollte
nur nicht sagen ihr dürft jetzt alle
michael jackson nicht mehr hören also
daraus ein gesetz praktisch machen dass
das finde ich dann zu viel ist schon
wieder zustimmt
ja also die frage wie wir mit
künstlerinnen umgehen die sich
beispielsweise strafbar gemacht haben
oder die anderweitig
aufgefallen sind negativ das kann er ist
eine große spannweite die ist deswegen
wichtig und auch für mich wichtig weil
ich das gefühl habe dass wir darüber
noch nicht so richtig sprechen können
also die fronten verhärten sich immer
sehr schnell wenn es um so etwas geht
und ich habe das gefühl haben noch
keinen weg gefunden darüber sinnvoll
konstruktives sprechen ich bin gespannt
ob heute einen schritt weiter gestern du
bist regisseur stellen wir uns mal
folgendes vor du inszeniert ein stück am
theater das läuft schon über einige
wochen das liedgut meinetwegen jeden
abend auf einmal passiert ein skandal
einer der schauspieler dieses
theaterstücks der hat sich strafbar
gemacht was tust du heute abend dass die
nächste show also ich hab mir die frage
stellen was denn die straftat ist ja ich
kann jetzt nicht eben über vielleicht
ein drogendelikt und einem eine
vergewaltigung kann sie sagen dass das
gleichwertig also wahrscheinlich würde
ich bei dem drogenkrieg sagen das soll
bitte spielen wenn ich hören würde dass
er eine kollegin vergewaltigt hat oder
irgendjemand anderes würde ich schon die
frage stellen dass man wie hat man ob
man überhaupt eine integrität hat auf
eine bühne zu gehen
und ja auch etwas mit dem werk erzählt
und dadurch dass man ja etwas begangen
hat was auch dem werk widerspricht ob
man das dann noch vertreten kann und im
gegensatz zu malerei glaube ich das
theater etwas was in dem moment halt
immer wieder stattfindet und dadurch ist
ja auch der schauspieler in dem moment
vertreter des kunstwerkes und wird auch
gewissermaßen selbst zum kunstwerk und
würde ja dem selber widersprechen wenn
du kannst auf keiner bühne in
deutschland allen ernstes so etwas wie
eine vergewaltigung vertreten da würde
ich durchaus sagen ist die person heute
hat nicht spielen kann der schauspieler
wird also zum teil des kunstwerks bei
billa du bist da einen schritt auf ihn
zugegangen ja ich finde er hat einen
wichtigen punkt genannt und zwar den
punkt drogen gelegt dass es sexuelle
gewalt
genau das ist ja die crux zu bestimmen
was ist denn schlimm was ist die
definition von schlimm und ich denke wir
kommen den man schritt näher wenn wir
das so betrachten
das jedes mal dann wenn der gemeinschaft
geschadet wird oder einem individuum
also wirklich gewalt zugefügt wird
gibt es einfach keine wirkliche kunst
freiheit mehr aber wie du gesagt hast
bei einem drogendelikt also ich finde
ich finde jetzt nicht dass man bei einem
drogendelikt jetzt den kompletten
künstler ausklammern muss und für mich
ist zum beispiel der besitz von
marihuana keine straftat und auch nicht
der handel dennoch ist das geltendes
gesetz ich glaube das also was legal und
was strafbar ist ist vielleicht nicht
das geeignete
nase aber ich glaube wenn wir zum
beispiel eine klaren
menschenrechtsverletzung ausgehen dazu
gehörten vergewaltigung gehörten
sexualdelikte etc das ist universell
etwas das man als glaube ich falsch
abtun kann wenn wir zum iran lebst und
dort mit einem menschen irgendwo benutzt
weil du homosexuell bis dass es dann
auch eine straftat insofern ist nicht
jede straftat zu wird also in welchem
kontext ist das eine straftat
aber ich glaube da sind wir uns weit das
kind eigentlich wollte ich denn da einig
weil dann könnt ihr euch gerne dazu
positionieren einmal an die gelbeseiten
menschenrechtsverletzungen als
eindeutige grenze ist das was wo ihr
euch eigentlich seid mit erst am 8
ist ein schritt also sofern tut das
grundgesetz als basis verstöße gegen das
grundgesetz ich sehe das als basis
verstöße gegen das grundgesetz ich habe
das beispiel war bei ebenso ein bisschen
verwirrend weil wenn der schauspieler am
tag man erfährt dass dann ist das ja
erst mal teil einer laufenden er mit ja
und dann muss man nicht erst mal raus
ziehen und dann wartet er praktisch also
wann weiß nicht stimmt das ist das
gedacht und dann wartet man bis sich das
gesetz darum kümmert dann wird er
verurteilt und dann kriegt er eine
gesetzliche strafe wenn die abgelaufen
ist hat er meine mama hat das recht
alles zu machen was er will jede art von
kunst weil die gesetzlich wurde diese
strafe gemacht und danach kann er
eigentlich wieder ein künstler werden du
redest von der rechtsstaatlichkeit aus
und da bin ich auf jeden fall dafür dass
wenn es keine eindeutigen belege gibt
dass man immer rechtsstaatliche
verfahren abwartet aber jetzt an haben
wir würden jetzt wissen und mitbekommen
wo eine garderobe hat eine kollegin mit
kollegin vergewaltigt und das muss
natürlich erst mal jetzt ein verfahren
durchgehen würde ich trotzdem als
restore diesem schauspieler aus der
produktion nehmen ohne dieses
rechtsstaatliche verfahren abzuwarten
weil es da bestimmte anhaltspunkte gebe
dass das durch was passiert ist bei
darstellende kunst bei filmen bei auch
beim musikproduktionen es ist
schwieriger als wenn ich vor einem
gemälde stehen oder wenn ich ein buch
schreibe weil da gibt es nur eine person
und das werk aber bei musikvideos bei
theater bei filmen bei serien hast du
einfach nur da gibt es einfach eine ganz
andere korrespondenz zwischen den
künsten und künstler/innen das ist das
ist ein schwer dadurch eine person quasi
dann alles raus zu nehmen das ist nicht
ein größeres verbrechen das ist wenn der
wenn das ist wenn der der typ ja einmal
zwei stars produziert hat von michael
jacksons beat it was ist wenn der mörder
ist man also was machst du dann also du
musst ja eigentlich auch sagen der hat
kunstwerk mit erschaffen und der war
auch teil im grunde
lange er durch seinen vielfachen mord
das kunstwerk nicht maßgeblich
mitgestaltet hat also wenn ich sein mord
nicht im kunsthaus manifestiert würde
ich sagen dann ist es nicht relevant das
meinte ich aber etwas ist halt sehr
komplex man ist total jacksons song von
dem ganzen studio und dem typen das
cover gemacht hat oder die frau und der
gehört als station des werkes in bochum
durch was du gesagt hast ein riesiges es
gibt halt auch noch ein aspekt wir uns
unterscheiden kann und das ist also
jetzt in deinem extrembeispiel mit dem
produzenten der dann doch irgendwie
zehnfacher mörder ist
das könnte man sich ja vorstellen
theoretisch dass er zumindest die morde
begangen hat ohne in dieser musik welt
unterwegs zu sein einfach weil er
möglicherweise einfach nur da ist und es
gibt aber eben verbrechen die sehr
spezifisch mit der kunstwelt oder mit
der musikwelt zu tun haben also und und
vielleicht sogar dadurch begünstigt
werden durch die hierarchischen
verhältnisse die das ist in dieser
michael jackson zeit vielleicht
vorherrschten und dann würde ich da auch
einmal anders tor reden glaube ich als
wenn sie jetzt aber dem würde ich wissen
wir ja zu stimmen an alouettes was sagen
ja ich könnte ja auch absolut recht dass
die kunstwelt und dpa der welt und die
musikwelt voller dieser hierarchien ist
die diese dinge nun mal begünstigen also
dann müsste man entweder die sich
hierarchien ändern und was mir dabei
auch klar geworden ist als wir darüber
gesprochen haben dass immer wenn es um
machtmissbrauch geht um mich rächen in
der kunstwelt geht eigentlich die man
nur um männer scheinbar gibt es das nur
so rum wenn man einfach künstlerverband
aus der kunstwelt also männer dann
problem gelöst es gibt leider auch
andersrum
autoritäre frauen gibt es auch also je
mehr je mehr frauen glaube ich in
machtpositionen kommen werden desto
häufiger werden wir diese fälle haben
vielleicht der zentral genug weniger
aber ich glaube diese illusion der
können wir uns jetzt nicht hingeben als
frauen das ist nur ein männerproblem ist
es ihr aber überzeugend finde ist wurde
kannst du nicht sag ich und bezeugen
finde es auf jeden fall die frage der
der machtstruktur nur die generell der
struktur ich glaube wenn man einen
bestimmten zum beispiel dabei uns am
theater mein opa gibt es eine sehr nach
oben gerichtete hier die die
intendantinnen bevor begünstigen
überhaupt macht zu missbrauchen
und wenn du sagst halt die mehr frauen
in position kommen umso mehr macht mich
oft kommen auch durch frauen dann muss
man auf jeden fall auch die strukturen
als solche mit zur verantwortung ziehen
aber die frage ist auch es geht immer um
zugänge also wenn jemand juwelen zum
beispiel straftat begangen hat und seit
60 jahren mit sehr hoch finanzierten
budgets filme dreht und jetzt trotzdem
an der mailänder scala an oper
inszenieren kann und weiterhin mit
budgets filme drehen kann es stellt sich
die frage ob man unabhängig davon ob man
jetzt ein vorheriges werk kennt oder
nicht ob man so einer person überhaupt
noch zugang möglich ermöglichen sollte
nachts ohne stars und da würde ich auch
eher sagen vielleicht braucht man keine
filme mehr von woody allen nachdem er
diese straftat begangen hat trotzdem
würde ich die stadtneurotiker
1960 relevante gedreht oder würde ich
mir immer wieder anschauen und würde
immer wieder bewundern was so ein toller
film das ist aber ich würde
wahrscheinlich sagen aber er sollte
heute eigentlich nicht mal voll
präsentierte filme drehen auf der
gegenseite sind alle ein schritt auf
mich zugegangen ich finde es muss ja
eigentlich um das was wir heute auch
schon angesprochen haben gehen um unter
welchen bedingungen passiert hast du was
kann man schon machen das ist nicht mehr
passiert und dann geht's halt glaube ich
mehr darum und das kann ja auch schon an
also wer bekommt eigentlich ist noch
fläche so weil die fläche die die in
hektischer kunst zur verfügung steht ja
immer auch begrenzt ist und
ich musste jetzt nicht irgendwie dass
michael die michael jackson alben auf
spotify gelöscht haben aber ich würde
mich schon wundern wenn rolling stone
dass jetzt noch fünf mal irgendwie als
cover führt da würde ich mich dann schon
ein bisschen beschweren es muss also
dass es trotzdem verfügbar bleiben und
kann ja kontextualisiert werden was da
wie das passiert ist man merkt also zu
diesem punkt der diskussion dass sehr
viele dinge tatsächlich individuelle
entscheidungen auch sind habe ich gerade
erst noch einen schritt auf dax zu
bewegt warum
das stimmt was
der fläche ja genau das genau das ist
nicht wichtiger punkt dass wir nicht
total wichtigen punkt also wo ich auch
sagen würde an der stelle macht es
keinen sinn den autor vom werk zu
trennen weil wir natürlich demografisch
und auch sonst sozial gucken müssen wer
bekommt überhaupt raum und
aufmerksamkeit wer darf sich durchsetzen
weil natürlich ist das werk sozusagen
das werk ist zwar theoretisch autonom
aber dass es über jahrhunderte von
weißen männern gemacht wurde kann kein
zufall sein sondern ist wiederum etwas
was wir aktiv bearbeiten müssen so und
dann kommt die verbindung zwischen der
persönlichkeit ist dessen der iss
gemacht hat und dem berg eben wieder
rein wenn man das jetzt mal
weiterspinnt balbina sollten dann nur
noch menschen kunst machen die die
straffrei sind die fehlerlos sind und
worin kommen wir dann geht das überhaupt
ich glaube es gibt niemanden der
fehlerlos ist und die definition von
straffrei ist für mich auch eine
schwierige wahl was was ist strafe
überhaupt ich glaube was mir jetzt auch
klar geworden ist in den letzten minuten
das uns an der begrenzung der
kunstfreiheit glaube ich am meisten
stört wenn sie vom staat aus betrieben
wird und wenn etwas auf den index kommt
aber womit wir alle irgendwie mehr oder
weniger d'accord sind ist das ein
diskurs geführt werden kann ja also auch
ihr die sagt kunstfreiheit sollte nicht
begrenzt werden und kann abgekoppelt vom
künstler wahrgenommen werden auch er
sagt natürlich dennoch wenn es
schwierige eine schwierige vita gibt
oder wenn es vorwürfe gibt im raum die
schwerwiegend sind dann kann der diskurs
eröffnet werden und ich glaube dass das
ist das wichtige dass das nicht von oben
runter plumps und der und der und der
darf jetzt nicht mehr sondern dass es
möglich ist heutzutage einen diskurs
über auch individuen die kunst
erschaffen zu führen dass das ok ist
weil das war eine lange zeit nicht okay
was man ihr dann sollten wir
künstlerinnen die sich strafbar gemacht
haben die bühne entziehen also zum
beispiel sie rausschneiden aus dem
programm nehmen sie nicht mehr im radio
spielen schreibt in die kommentare
einmal bei diesem diskurs zu bleiben wie
wir alle wissen entsteht kunst auch
häufig auf der straße sei es jetzt raps
street art wie können wir dann
verhindern dass genau dieser diskurs er
hier nur
in einer akademischen elitären babbel
sage ich mal stattfindet und dass wir
damit menschen ausschließen die
ausschließen die aufgrund ihrer
sozialisierung eben nicht den zugang
dazu hatten also ganz konkret wie
kriegen wir diesen diskurs von twitter
auch auf eben jene straße wo kunst
häufig entsteht also ich finde man muss
es trotzdem versuchen zu retten zu
erklären was es kunst und ein künstler
ist nicht gleich seinem werk ein
schauspieler ist nicht das was er
darstellt ein sänger ist nicht das was
er segen sondern also diese differenz
das ist glaube ich eher dass schwierige
den leuten zu erklären weil ich glaube
intuitiv verwechseln wahnsinnig viele
leute den schauspieler mit der rolle den
rapper mit dem wahnsinn ruft ja ja nun
gerade auf twitter aber das gute an
twitter ist ja dass jeder künstler oder
auch jeder aus dem publikum sozusagen
heutzutage sich dann auch dazu äußern
kann also jeder kunstschaffende kann ja
auch sagen im moment ihr habt nicht
falsch verstanden ich bin nicht homophob
oder ich meinte das nicht so aber wenn
jemand das dann immer wieder tut und
sozusagen immer wieder ebenso wie xavier
naidoo oder sowas immer wieder die
gleiche so wiederholt dann weise auch
irgendwann das publikum wiederum okay
jetzt du hattest deine 50ct chancen wenn
du sie alle verspielt hat aber in dem
fall von ciena du hast ja auch tour ist
eine äußerung der letzten jahre weil ich
habe früher sehr gerne ich muss mich
jetzt auch seine musik gehört ja als ich
15 war vielleicht sogar als ich noch 16
sie hat einfach dazu aber wer nicht also
nach dem was er sagte sein werk noch mal
betrachtet haben und das ist auch
spannend wie quasi die äußerung eines
künstlers das eigene werk plötzlich
beeinflussen können indem es eine andere
sichtbarkeit macht für das was er damals
eigentlich schon immer in dem werk drin
hatte was man damals aber noch nicht
gesehen hat und
das fand ich da will ich aber gerne
widersprechen weil ich finde ja klar
also aus der rückschau es ist so ein
bisschen wie beim fußball so wie man das
ergebnis kennt das ist jetzt gut
erklären was da passiert ist ich glaube
aber dass bei xavier naidoo
beispielsweise bei der art von musik die
er gemacht hat nur konkret bei dem
beispiel zu bleiben natürlich wenn man
das jetzt finden will dann sieht man
auch ja da da hat da war es schon drin
der große freiheit gedanke oder hier die
große skepsis gegen die regierung aber
das hätte er natürlich auch in 45 andere
richtungen dann auch sich in jacken
gegönnt und ist nicht zwangsläufig dass
er jetzt irgendwie bei querdenken
gespielt wird das dass du eigentlich ein
schönes beispiel oder der sl hat sorgt
dafür dass das was die leute freiwillig
gehören da muss man gar nichts zensieren
man kann die da weiterhin irgendwie auf
der bravo hits 17 lassen wenn ein lied
meine lippen verlässt ist immer noch ein
schöner song
und man guckt sich den typen aber ganz
besonders mit ganz anderen mann schaut
ihnen ganz anders als die meisten seiner
songs und das ist glaube ich ein
hoffnungszeichen dass die leute auch
ganz gut zum teil selber geregelt
konserviert und ist auch deswegen hab
ich ein gutes beispiel weil er so ein
bisschen auch
stellvertretend ist für so ein bisschen
denn den wandel vielleicht so von
künstlern so mit social media und so
weiter also kommt ja eigentlich aus
einer zeit wo es vorüber bravo usw die
berichterstattung lief man gar nicht so
viel selber einfluss darauf hatte und
dann am ende mit dem eigenen telegramm
kanal und gespielter zehntausende und
ist auf plötzliche plötzlich ganz anders
unmittelbarer bei den leuten dem zuhören
und viel ungefilterte also da schaut
kein manager mehr darüber was er jetzt
wieder neue theorie möglicherweise hat
und das ist irgendwie auch bei ihm ganz
spannend weil ich glaube dass das halt
für viele künstlerinnen auch aus dem
bereich den luca gemeintes rap und soul
das ist ja auch sehr viele kennen es
nicht anders als das das wir hier leben
über instagram und zwei teilen und
dadurch entsteht aber glaube ich auch
beim publikum oder bei uns also eine
andere erwartungshaltung sobald also
eben nicht irgendwie abgehobene figuren
in seinem jüngsten sohn sind sehr nah
bei uns und deswegen haben wir auch
bestimmte erwartungen möglicherweise an
sie die wir auch an unser umfeld haben
weil sie das nachwirken ich habe jetzt
ein kompromissvorschlag für euch
vielleicht überzeugt er euch und ihr
macht alle den schritt ins kompromiss
fällt unsere klicks bei streaming
anbietern unsere kinokarten unsere käufe
in im buchladen und in galerien die sind
ein politisches gut wenn wir
problematische künstler/innen
finanzieren haben sie auch große
reichweiten und niemand muss das
unterstützen sind wir uns einig dass
unser konsumverhalten große auswirkungen
auf bestehende strukturen hat und wir
deshalb genau reflektieren sollten wem
wir unsere aufmerksamkeit
wenn er sagt ja dann könnt ihr jetzt
einen schritt auf mich zugehen
[Musik]
ich bin noch nicht ganz da alle sind so
einen kleinen schritt aber ich zu gast
am meisten beziffert peter ja weil also
ich stimme dem schon zu man sollte sich
das überlegen wie man das aber
ich mache ja selber auch halt also ich
habe die ganze zeit morris hier an der
zum teil privat relativen rechte thesen
hat aber ich mag die musik so gerne dass
ich es auch selber nicht durchziehen
dass er uns sogar ob ich da wirklich
zustimmen sollte
außerdem muss man nicht vergessen kunst
ist nicht sauber und manchmal ist auch
kunst total toll gerade weil man
irgendwie weiß der typ der das gemacht
hat ist nicht ganz es ist nicht komplett
irgendwie ethisch super sondern das ist
vielleicht ein total versoffener idiot
und dann finde ich es trotzdem
interessant oder wie bei caravaggio der
wahre mörder und die die werke sind toll
und man hat irgendwie das gefühl da ist
so eine überschreitung drin so eine
kraft also was haben wir noch gar nicht
gesagt dass ich meine vielleicht
vielleicht ist auch irgendwie so scheiß
drauf vielleicht ist trotzdem das
kunstwerk so gut dass ich da jetzt nicht
ganz darüber nachdenken möchte was
hatten der hat er seine steuererklärung
ordentlich gemacht und ist ja eigentlich
immer brav sohn also das jetzt polemisch
aber absolut aber diese dirty sexy es
gibt es nur für männer so die ganzen was
er sich von rezepten bis keine ahnung
dreckig auf drogen irgendwie heute aber
wenn du als frau besoffen wenn man
einmal dein schläppi sorry beim sein
auto steigen bist du eine schlechte
mutter sie aber das müssen wir ändern
oder zu stärken dass sie irgendwann
einen ryder nachdem sie halt geklaut hat
ja so geben wir werden das hat mir klar
dass frauen sollten die privilegien
haben und das privileg haben dirty zu
sagen
frauen dürfen ich heiße bauen und wir
finden sie immer noch gut dann könnt ihr
da eigentlich auch noch mal einen
kleinen schritt
verdienen könnt und jetzt übergebe ich
an euch ihr könnt jetzt auf jedem feld
noch mal die köpfe zusammenstecken und
auch wenn ihr schon halb um kompromiss
fed seit noch mal überlegen was ist
jetzt eigentlich euer konkreter
kompromissvorschlag das kann auch nur
konkrete forderung sein was auch immer
die ihr der anderen seite gerne
präsentieren wollen ebenso lange drogen
ist wieder rein fallen
müssen überfordert mit smidt-arena weil
eigentlich sind wir glaube ich alle
sechs einer meinung ist bis jetzt
wiederum kann jetzt dass es rechtlich
freigesprochen was meint ihr seiten wir
künstler innen die sich strafbar gemacht
haben die bühne im stil und wo wäre da
für euch die grenze schreibt mal in die
kommentare es geht halt wirklich um die
verantwortung auch würde man da sagen
dass man das dass über diese szene
streichen sollte er weiß nicht
was du bist unser referat ist fertig
also an die grüne seite was habt ihr
euch überlegt was ist euer
kompromissvorschlag an das gelbe fällt
unser kompromissvorschlag ist wir
bleiben dabei dass wir künstler und werk
trennen aber wir finden es absolut
sinnvoll wenn man sagt man möchte ein
künstler eine künstlerin nicht weiter
unterstützen man möchte ihnen sie nicht
ökonomisch stärken man möchte ihn
sichtbarkeit entziehen dass man das dann
über diesen weg macht aus sagt er geht
er einen schritt auf die grüne seite zog
grundsätzlich positiv dass thommy so der
konsens auf den wir alle sechs schon
einigermaßen hatten
ja könnte ich jetzt nichts gegen sagen
okay gut dann könnte ein schritt nach
vorne gehen jetzt ist er es vor
und jetzt könnt ihr euren
kompromissvorschlag vortragen die grünen
seien männer heraus ist der kunst nein
das stimmt
ja
nein ja wir uns überlegt wir das ist
auch kein kompromiss und ich glaube wir
sind da auch wiederum alle einer meinung
dass wir generell eigentlich in sehr
vielen punkten wahrscheinlich einer
meinung sind der muss doch überlegt wir
als konsul kulturschaffende haben ja
eine bestimmte verantwortung und wir
haben ja auch eine besondere macht die
nämlich darüber hinaus geht als nur zu
sagen ich kaufe das konzertticket nicht
sondern wir können ja auch unsere
kollegen sozusagen kritisch beäugen wir
können sagen 'mit dir trete ich nicht
auf mit dir schnell ich nicht aus und
diese macht sollten wir auch ausnutzen
und ergänzen will würden wir das
vielleicht noch um den kompromiss
schrägstrich forderungen fragen also in
dieser disco und auch immer wieder
fragen auf die sehr auf den einzelnen
abzielen hörst du noch den und den
künstler oder wie gehst du damit um dass
du mit spotify und an der kinokasse den
und den künstler noch support ist und
ich finde dass so ein bisschen wohlfeil
weil man blockiert sich irgendwie selber
damit dann an punkt zu kommen wo man
tatsächlich etwas ändern könnte
natürlich gibt es irgendwo eine
verantwortung beim einzelnen aber das
ist dann so so komplex und so schwierig
und wieder allgemein was zu formulieren
dass es mir oder auch uns wie wir gerade
festgestellt haben eher darum geht wer
hat denn wirklich macht sozusagen in den
einzelnen kunst betrieben was zu
verändern also wer fördert zum beispiel
in der bildenden kunst oder in der
literatur
wer stellt festivals auf und so weiter
ich glaube wenn diese leute ans umdenken
kommen dann ist um einiges mehr gewonnen
als wenn jetzt der einzelne aufhört
michael jackson zu hören
dass wir zustimmen würde
ja sehr sehr gutes argument es gibt nun
mal sehr viele künstler die die
fragwürdig sind neue wagner wie auch
immer statt die vielleicht alle
sozusagen herauszunehmen aus der kultur
weil wir uns dann wiederum ja auch ins
eigene fleisch schneiden würden geht
vielmehr um kontext ist und darum wie
man historisch dinge die noch mal
betrachtet ja dem kann ich nichts
hinzufügen
aber ich plädiere auf noch mal was wir
heute glaube ich gelebt haben in dem
gespräch dass man dieses thema
ausdifferenziert und dass man eben nicht
pauschal nach eine antwort sucht die auf
diese frage zu finden ist weil die wird
man nicht finden die kann man mit einer
art mit einem satz auch nicht
beantworten man muss die
ausdifferenzierung man muss die kunst
bereiche unterscheiden muss eine
straftat von anderen vergehen
unterscheiden man kann das nicht
beantworten
vielleicht muss man sich von dem versuch
verabschieden diese frage klar
beantworten zu wollen ich würde sagen
dass ich das lange nicht mehr gesehen
hat dass so viele leute im kompromiss
fels und ich danke euch für die
diskussion
ich finde die diskussion hat sehr gut
gezeigt wie unfassbar komplex dieses
thema ist einmal muss man erst mal
darüber diskutieren was überhaupt kunst
ist wo die anfängt wo die aufhört dann
muss man darüber sprechen wo sind die
grenzen das ist natürlich auch sehr
individuell ab wann wird eine grenze
überschritten diese empfindung und dann
als drittes natürlich wer entscheidet
darüber die gesellschaft die justiz also
da gibt es noch sehr viele weitere
diskussionen die wir zu dem thema führen
können falls ja auch bei der nächsten
diskussion dabei sein wollt dann lasst
doch gerne ein abo für diesen kanal da
hier oben findet ihr ein weiteres video
von 13 fragen und hier unten ein
weiteres video zum thema